very difficult I mean clearly we have to
keep a close eye on the Kremlin enablers
you know that there is of course some
pretty solid support for this one this
special military operation there are
many uh members of the Russian armed
forces have committed atrocities now but
again not everybody has done this and so
I do think that we have to bear in mind
that over the longer term and that's you
know sometimes still often the
foreseeable future we will have to
re-engage
you know a lot of people I mean we've
heard macron talk about Don humiliate
Russia I think that that's a because it
might turn out to be like by my Germany
but already beyond that I mean Russia
has gone through its five more period
and we're already in the you know
full-on you know invasion of Poland plus
and if we're thinking about a World War
II analogy I mean Russia and Putin have
only humiliated themselves but there is
a point of over the longer term that you
know we can't ignore that Russia is
there and short of a complete and at a
loss of war and an occupation of Russia
which of course didn't happen during the
Cold War the end of the Cold War and you
know it was unlikely to have happened in
this case too it's going to be very hard
to get Russians to come to terms with
what they've done and we'll only be able
to do that by engaging you know with
people who genuinely see things
differently
um you know I think the German and the
Japanese experience of you know kind of
coming to terms with a peer Alexis and
wartime atrocities of course happened
under circumstances of occupation and
you know we can engage with the Germans
and Japanese and others to kind of think
about that because at some point the
Russians are going to have to come to
terms with as they tried to during the
Gorbachev period an early elsin period
you know with what has happened in here
because otherwise you're going to have
generations of enmity you know to
overcome not just with ukrainians but
with most of Europe as well which is not
going to be sustainable for Russia over
the longer term this isn't a great you
know kind of answer here but I think we
have to think about this as you've
already laid out in different terms it's
not as one single approach I think we
have short medium and long-term issues
that we have to factor in here
yes and I I think that this business of
of trying to move towards a
post-imperial Russia Russia that's an
actual nation state and doesn't Define
itself in terms of controlling
um other groups either within its
borders or
um Beyond them is an arable long-term
goal
it's very hard to see how we get there
at the moment barring a catastrophic
military defeat right and of course the
problem with that is that um if Putin
winning is very scary pushing losing is
pretty scary as well because
um you mentioning that on foreign policy
article I referred to at the beginning
his favorite story about the cornered
rat and if you did have a 1918 style
military disintegration where an
overstretched under-resourced military
starts shooting its officers going home
mutinying um and you see a bit of a
military collapse going on even in parts
of perhaps not all the front but um in
bits of it
that would be an existential threat to
Putin where he might then try and try
and escalate and I'm wondering how you
and and this is in a way one of the
great bogeymen if um in in in the
western discourses oh my goodness
pushing's so crazy we don't know what he
do so we better better not not quote
humiliate unquote and we we can't afford
to have Putin losing so how should we
think about this danger of escalation is
it is it as real as some of the fear
mongers and do mongers make out
well first of all he's not crazy
um but look we've had Putin around now
for 22 years
um and I think many people who are
listening to this too have you know kind
of
made some assessments of Him in all this
time we actually know a lot more about
him than we used to and you have to
remember that you know as you said here
a lot of these stories that we hear
about Putin's story is that he himself
has put forward because he wants to
create a certain image the story of the
rap is his own story that he tells you
know uh journalists for his
semi-autobiographical book that is his
campaign book for being cemented in the
position of President back in 99 2000
and a lot of the stories about Putin's
risk taking and the kind of Assessments
of him come from that from this kind of
creating a certain image that he has to
live up to
now you know he's also a rational actor
in his own rationale in his own context
you know people remember that you know
um Angela Merkel said that he's a man
who lived in his own world which doesn't
mean that you know he collabs in an
alternate universe he lives in a
carefully framed and calculated uh
context of his own with his own sets of
Assessments here just like you know I
said before he actually probably
assesses he's not doing that badly in
the war although where we would look at
it from our own perspective and think
well that's nuts I mean he hasn't
achieved any of his
original goals but Putin always again as
the operative somebody who was a
contingency planner thinks okay well I
have my my goals I have my strategic
perspectives here and if the first thing
doesn't work then I'll just try another
thing and then I'll try another thing
it's adaptation he always tells you
stories about adaptation as well like
water if it can't get down one channel
it'll find another and so he's always
you know finding another way uh to get
to the uh get to the same point now if
that were then as you're suggesting if
things start to look a little dire
you know we've already seen them do the
nuclear subrattling I mean in many
respects he's already
rhetorically deployed nuclear weapons
and used them because it's got everybody
scared and running around so we have to
you know bear in mind that that's the
kind of thing he does so how do we get
ahead of it
um one of the um things that uh is worth
bearing in mind for example is that they
take a very careful reader version about
how we react
so we think about when they move through
the Chernobyl exclusion Zone the the
military forces
Putin was paying attention the fact that
everybody said oh they wouldn't possibly
go through Chernobyl why would they do
that I mean that's just horrific I mean
why would they think about doing that
because of course they go all the way
through and they scare the heck out of
everyone by not just stirring up the
dust the toxic dust that's going to
actually you know probably host of
cancer cases in all of the young
conscripts that were sent through that
but it's it's basically stirs up the
dust of time people like me and you and
others you know remember the Chernobyl
um explosion and the fact that we were
all irradiated in Europe with the plume
going over and so everybody's fears
about nuclear power and how that can go
wrong gets stirred up again same thing
with zaparesia the largest nuclear plant
in Europe they deliberately shelled it
deliberately sheltered that wasn't an
accident and the timing was of course so
opposite because
this was in the period when the Germans
are debating whether they extend the
life of their nuclear plants in order to
try to offset these problems that
they're going to face with natural gas
coming in from Russia and similarly the
Japanese are trying to figure out
whether they kind of rev up again their
nuclear power system notwithstanding all
the fears from Fukushima and of course
Germany and Japan are tied together in
this kind of nuclear reaction after that
uh explosion and accident after the
tsunami in Japan with Fukushima and so
all of this is happening at the same
time because Putin knows he can push our
buttons he knows our fears and he can
play to our fears so we then have to get
ahead of this we have to have a serious
open discussion about it and we have to
figure out how we're going to tackle it
in uh before anything happens and so I
think that that's the only way to deal
with is to talk about it talk about it
calmly lay it all out and to realize
that this guy is pushing our buttons
because in a psychological operation the
things that Putin was trying to
participate in you defeat the the enemy
before you even get to the battlefield
now in this case he hasn't managed that
but the whole idea is that you tell
everybody you can't possibly win give up
now and that's just basically what he's
trying to tell us yeah
I want to come to questions in a moment
so there are many excellent questions
and also a daunting list of Russia
experts who've tuned into our discussion
um many of whom would be um we could um
profitably listen listen to for many
minutes or indeed ours but I I I one of
the things my final question before we
get onto on onto the wider discussion is
that I find so frustrating that we are
always doing things too late and I'm
wondering if you could just we could
just spool back to February the 24th or
indeed February the 23rd we put tens of
billions of dollars of support financial
support into Ukraine probably not enough
because Ukraine's in a part of State we
put enormous efforts into military
supplies we put sweeping sanctions on
Russia
um none of it's really worked we've
reverted disaster we haven't got victory
it's really quite daunting to think if
if one tenth of that political energy
have been devoted to the problem
beforehand
um presumably it would have deterred
Putin and this wouldn't have happened
well yes I mean I think that's a fair
point because I mean we we know
um from long experience and everybody
likes to quote the idea of the accident
of Lenin you know you kind of push and
if you kind of you know essentially get
most you keep on going and if you hit
something hard you know with a burner
then you stop if you hit steel you pull
back
um I haven't put that as quite as
artfully as it's normally quoted but
it's burned I think if you yes exactly
yeah
but I mean basically we know that you
know kind of they will keep on Putin and
the people around him again as an
operative we'll keep on trying and you
know if you kind of succeed you keep on
going and then when you stop you um you
um fall back but you know the thing is
that they um Putin and the Kremlin have
an incredible advantage over all of us
because he's been in power again for 22
years essentially with the same cast of
characters around him just moving seats
he doesn't have a free media anymore he
doesn't really have any kind of
opposition
and there's no compulsion you know every
time he has a new Administration so to
speak or a new term in office to shuffle
people around think about how many U.S
presidents Prime Ministers of you know
Italy for example you know the places
that uh Putin has gone through in all of
this time
we are democracies we're very messy
we're not very stable yeah we have uh
changes of administration in places like
the United States we then you know kind
of have to go cycle through all kinds of
political appointees many people are not
um actually in place they have
ambassadors who are not in place uh if
you think back to the Trump
Administration multiple National
Security advisors and you know
secretaries of state and secretaries of
defense
we haven't got any continuity we dropped
the ball we lose sight of the ball all
the time that is actually the main
obstacle for us to be able to put in
some consistent process that means that
Putin always hits bone or steal all the
way along and of course we now know that
he's trying to game all of this out he
said it openly that he actually believes
that New Elites will come into power
we've had Mario draghi's government fall
in Italy we've had of course Marine Le
Pen emerged more successfully out of the
French elections we're having uh Prime
ministerial in a changeover and
potentially you know kind of more
upheaval in the United Kingdom we have
the midterms in the United States Putin
basically figures out that yes I mean
the reason the democracies lose focus is
because they're always kind of changing
over all the time and we don't have
systems put in place to basically deal
with this in a consistent fashion